avanza la investigación Angélica
Hinojosa una de las guardias de
seguridad del centro de detención de
migrantes ubicado en Ciudad Juárez donde
murieron 39 personas habló a la prensa
según ella el encargado de la unidad de
hombres salió del edificio antes de que
se iniciara la conflagración un nuevo
detalle Que cuestiona si el principal
del área de detención masculina quien
además controlaba la llave de acceso a
la cárcel pudo salvar a los detenidos la
llave La resguardan ellos ellos son los
que tienen la llave
Pues no creo que se las haya llevado la
saga de Haber puesto colgada Donde están
todas las llaves Igual nosotros siempre
que Les deseamos hoy es que pues llegó
gente yo digo que las puso ahí Ahí
estaba la llave Nada más que pues nadie
me imagino que nadie corrió la oficial
de guardia pudo rescatar a las mujeres a
su cargo mientras las investigaciones
avanzan el presidente mexicano Andrés
Manuel López Obrador hizo un llamado de
atención a Estados Unidos señaló al
vecino del Norte por su falta de ayuda a
los migrantes para que no sucedan
siniestros como el incendio de esta
semana
lo que hemos pedido al gobierno de
Estados Unidos es que si nosotros
estamos destinando 100 millones de
dólares pónganle ustedes ayuden Y no lo
han hecho ni con el presidente Trump
logramos Esto ni ahora con el presidente
biden este viernes la Secretaría de
Seguridad y protección Ciudadana de
México anunció el cierre definitivo de
la estación de aprehensión donde ocurrió
la catástrofe